congratulations on winning big at the
gotham award that just is so exciting
for everyone involved in this project
who out of the cast is the first to get
very very excited when it comes to this
type of recognition and who's ready to
party
peter for sure
like ready to dance yeah yeah but i feel
like
party is olivia yes true true true
apologies
yeah and who gets very excited i don't
know
we all do
yeah
well congratulations it's so exciting
you know peter you're in this really
awesome position of obviously working
with the the living and and and you know
uh working with the the writer director
maggie gyllenhaal on this with her first
uh directorial debut
what was it like for you watching the
beginning process of her writing this
knowing she wanted to direct this film
then directing you in it so you're
essentially there from the beginning to
the end what was that whole process like
for you
well you know i have no faith in the
world so when she first told me she
wanted to
do this i think my reaction was
something like
half a syllable i was like
and uh
i mean i thought that it was great and
all along the way
i would read scripts and talk to her
about it and stuff but
as good as it was i just i just didn't
have a lot of faith that the world would
accept such a thing
and it really was only until we were on
the beach
in greece sitting there and the cast
were arriving that i started to think
oh my god how did how the hell does she
do this you know maggie mac i i'm
somebody who's very good at thinking of
all sorts of interesting things that we
might do or should do
but uh she actually makes them happen
that's pretty incredible to watch and
then what was that process like having
her direct you were you excited about
that were there any nerves where you
know that's never happened before
yeah i was more nervous than usual
because yeah you know
i mean how bad paul how bad would it
have been if i'd just shown up and like
this
[Laughter]
i'm sorry my husband you know like her
making like weird apologies and going to
have private conversations with me in
another room to try to talk me down and
it's not working and my mouth is yeah i
mean all of that enters my mind
oh my god did you tell maggie that
that's funny
she could tell she you know when i did
my first take of any scene in the movie
i think
maggie just uh i think she went like
this
meaning do it again
and then she went like that do it again
do it again she just pounded it out of
me until i had no i couldn't defend
myself and i could just act you know
i love that well she knows how to direct
so well i mean all the performance in
this are so fantastic how was it like
having maggie is your director
it's a pretty incredible place to start
for like my first film to that yeah
maggie behind the camera um
she's
just incredible like she understands the
actor's process i think down to a t and
like as peter said like from take to
take
there would be room to kind of explore
and play and i think that that is like
one of the strengths of the film is that
there's dynamic performances throughout
so i think that's a
testament to maggie
absolutely testament you know to your
performance as well i mean you have
these wonderful scenes with olivia
coleman what was it like working with
her
she's the greatest uh
like it's from everybody i don't know
like i feel like anybody who ever
mentions anything about olivia's just
that she's the greatest like so
unbelievably unbelievably talented
and generous and i feel like from a cast
perspective she just
led from the front both as like a as an
actor and also just as like a
leadership figure among success so yeah
i've like nothing but the most amazing
things to say about olivia
i love that you know just watching this
movie you know this is a true depiction
of women of motherhood and all its
complexities peter what
did you love about this script and this
story
you know
i liked i i liked the thriller element
always you know i mean i think she was
working on it and showing it to me i was
always somebody who was like
that that for some reason that was where
my focus was um
just like
the the subtle interesting ways that she
manages to turn the screw tighter
you know and many of the ways that i
remember suggesting along the way were
were quite conventional
you know i'd be like
what if they they well i'm not going to
ruin the whole movie but like there are
lots of what if this happened wouldn't
that make it crazier and i think that's
always where my mind goes for some
reason you know keep them pinned to
their seats and that's the nice thing
about maggie is that she found another
way to pin people
to their seats than my sort of
one that has learned from 1980s
television
there's there's so many moments that are
unnerving because you're really not sure
what olivia coleman's going to say or do
and i i think there are so many moments
of that where you're almost like holding
your breath because there's there's this
tension and maggie captures that so well
um
in terms of your shooting location where
did you shoot this
we were in a spetz's greece it was um
the most
beautiful
island we were also it was like
right at the tail end i think we were
one of the first things to go post
pandemic happening we arrived on this
crazy beautiful island in greece and we
were kind of
there for what you were there for long i
was there for about six weeks
and yeah wow it was just incredible
yeah i was there for three months yeah
oh my god so when you're working on a
project that's so close to you peter and
you're working on this beautiful island
that's did you did you have a moment
where you were like yeah this this is
this is real life this is happening
i mean we felt incredibly fortunate i
mean all this
very very difficult stuff's happening
worldwide
so many people are dying so that's not
lost on me
um
but
if
you know i i think it's i i have a
friend growing up who became a doctor
and because i became an actor he used to
say i don't understand why what you do
has any
real need in the world like obviously
what i do i'm
you know saving people and i really took
that to heart for a long time i used to
think what i did was incredibly
pointless especially in the face of
things like this but then you realize
without this type of thing
we would really be suffering without
introspection without
looking after the heart and trying to
figure out
why we do things and all of the things
that that cinema exposes
we would really really be suffering so i
think
to remind ourselves that it's necessary
even though the conditions we're doing
it under were
i mean we were like the most fortunate
people i knew we were on an island
quarantined in greece
able to express ourselves in a way that
i haven't really since i mean on a lot
of sets now you know there's all these
different zones and there's no
interacting and stuff
um so
it was it was pretty incredible
well congratulations on this film i'm so
excited i i don't even know megan i'm so
excited for her i mean this just must be
so rewarding for all of you but
especially her congratulations you guys
thank you so much
you